hey guys it is the tenth of July today
my name is jeff mcdonald and you're
watching games but news first up today
Sony have sold so many consoles 100
million to be exact that's encompass
increse ps4 and vitas Sony included the
giant number in a video designed to
encourage the party manufacturers to
create peripherals for the system in
November we heard that the ps3 had sold
18 million units and in April we were
told that the ps4 had just passed seven
million units sold as from Microsoft
they told us in October of last year
that the 360 had just sold over 80
million ambers of April they'd shipped
five million Xbox one's the comparisons
sake Nintendo's kicked it out of the
park having sold more than 100 million
ways over 35 million 3d ass units and
just over 6 million we use as much it's
cool i'll do the math that's over 141
million system sold for nintendo and
user makes me very angry and very sad
apparently whatever demographic has
decided to pick up the mobile game Kim
Kardashian Hollywood may spend 200
million bucks in in-app purchases the
200 million figure was formulated by
industry analyst Doug Kurtz in a
Bloomberg feature on the game and if the
amount is Matt will be double what ea's
free-to-play game the simpsons tapped
out took in over the space of a year the
Kim Kardashian game has been out for two
weeks and lets you embody and
up-and-coming celebrity who visits clubs
and buys expensive houses as if you
needed more cause for frustration the
dev CEO then called mrs. Kanye West a
one-of-a-kind talent when an incredibly
precise fit to the gay mentioned that we
tailored but already had in the company
and in less blood-curdling news Ubisoft
have reported that they've had a huge
sales increase over their first quarter
mostly thanks to watch dogs the
company's earnings report indicated that
the game helps you B's turtle sales
jumped by three hundred and seventy-four
percent to 360 million euros year we
have apparently shipped more than eight
million copies of watch dogs in this
time but as for the actual cell through
we haven't heard anything more after the
four million you
sold in the first week figure from a
while back UV said they're expecting to
sell six million units in the game's
lifetime in regard to the company's
general success ennis they also jumped
149 percent in digital sales thanks to
watch dogs trials fusion child of light
and valiant hearts and lastly today
marks left have decided to be a product
and platform company instead of a
devices and services one okay cool let's
talk about what this actually means for
Xbox CEO Satya Nadella who said that
xbox isn't going anywhere particularly
since the business as the whole benefits
from technologies created from gaming
efforts including core graphics and Nui
in Windows speech recognition in skype
camera technology for Kinect for Windows
Azure cloud enhancements for GPU
simulation and many more he said a lot
of other things including the words
critical and fundamental which are less
interesting but concluded that the
biggest digital life category four
people in terms of time and money
investment is gaming and as for your
question of the day who is your favorite
publisher of games from this year so far
is that Ubisoft with all their formerly
mentioned offerings or somebody
completely different let me know that is
it for me today tomorrow I'll be back
with my top 5 favorite stories of the
whole gaming week so be sure to join me
then